(missile whooshing)
- On Wednesday evening,
North Korea launched
two ballistic missiles
off its east coast
for the first time since March this year.
North Korea state media released photos
and videos of the launch,
and it was conducted from a railway
in North Korea's central region.
State media referred to them
as railway-borne missiles.
We see in the footage that
a train slowly comes out
of the tunnel.
We see some people in hazmat suits
that come out preparing for the launch.
The anchor in the video says
that the launch occurred
at dawn on September 15th.
And this was the first
time that North Korea
was showing off its
railway-borne missile technology.
(missile booming)
The missiles flew about 500 miles
at an altitude of 37 miles
before splashing into the waters
between Korea and Japan,
which has caused alarm for officials.
What's unique is that North Korea
has an extensive railway network,
and this means South Korean
and US officials now have to
track rail-launched missiles,
as well as road launchers and
submarine-launched missiles.
North Korea has kept quiet
for quite a long time
since the pandemic began.
North Korea has been consumed
by domestic problems.
It's kept its borders closed
largely due to COVID fears
and has admitted to food shortages.
A lot of North Korea watchers say
that this recent missile launch indicates
that North Korea wants to
not only ramp up pressure
but also get the US to
pay attention to them,
and resume dialogue.
(missile booming)
Weapons tests are definitely
one of the methods
that North Korea uses to dial
up pressure on Washington.
Many experts that I've spoken to
have said that because the
US has been so consumed
with Afghanistan and other
international matters,
this was sort of a chance for North Korea
to grab their attention
and say we're still here.
We still have our weapons,
and we still have this
military power to show off.
And they're basically hoping
to use that as leverage
once negotiations do eventually resume.
(missile whooshing)